[Music]
Disneyland is the happiest place on
earth
but perspex view it's a job that comes
with strict rules tiring schedules and
plenty of workplace drama stay tuned to
see the crazy training these princesses
go through don't forget to hit that
notification valve to never miss another
video and to be sure to check out our
community section for even more fun now
let's check out what it takes to be a
Disneyland princess crazy audition
process
Disneyland might be a place for all your
wishes come true but unfortunately it's
quite a different place for people who
actually work there you won't believe
the crazy audition process who has to
undertake to even become a Disneyland
princess the auditions for Disneyland
princesses are extremely competitive a
former Disney Princess spoke out on what
the audition process actually looks like
first thing you should know is that you
can't audition for just the princess you
love unfortunately you don't get to
choose your role this former Disney
princess states that there were 500
people present in her audition flaunting
exactly the same thing as her to get
that dream Disneyland gig the judges
line the girls up in rows and study
their features that's right
it's all about that Disney look to fit
in you need to be between 5 feet 4
inches and 5 feet 7 inches tall to have
the perfect body type you can have the
best entertainment industry backgrounds
but without the perfect to look your
Disney dreams might never come true and
out of all those 500 people like this
audition only three girls were selected
to become Disney Princesses yep you
heard that right
just three and the worst part is you can
only audition once per year crazy
costumes if you've ever been to Disney
Land
you've probably noticed all Disney
Princesses always play and look the part
at all times unless the princess has had
a bad day which very rarely happens
anyways you'll never see her without a
perfect costume and that's because this
is part of their strict costuming rules
you're required to be in Disney clothing
from start to finish of your shift and
you absolutely cannot walk around and
any other clothing while on the job
after all that would totally ruin the
magic wouldn't it the biggest part of
being a Disney princess is wearing
wig if you're a full-time performer you
get your own wig part-time performers
have wigs which are washed before the
start of their every shift and if you
wonder why they always look so OnPoint
it's because some of the wigs get styled
and cleaned every two days so if you're
not comfortable with wearing wigs at all
times it's something you'll have to do
if you want to become a Disney Princess
although we're not sure you'll want to
become one after you hear our next few
dark truths this job isn't exactly all
that magical after all makeup gurus if
you're a disneyland princess you'll have
to love makeup the truth is you'll be in
charge of your own makeup as a princess
and you absolutely have to get it right
former Disney princes have noted that
they have a cosmetologist in the break
room but they mostly take care of the
wigs when you're a Disneyland princess
you actually learn how to do the makeup
for your character during your training
yep Disneyland princesses do their own
makeup for every single shift and since
you really don't know the character
you'll end up with it's always best to
come with some makeup knowledge to ease
yourself in if contour is the bane of
your existence it's best to practice in
advance but the good news is that
Disneyland provide you with all
necessary makeup you'll need for your
princess look Disneyland uses vinay
makeup products for their princesses
because of the special pigmentation
you'll have to think of every day as a
photo shoot a Disney Princess has to be
ready to take a photo at all times and
she must always look flawless time to
start watching some YouTube makeup
tutorials and get that Disney Princess
lookdown autograph learning remember
when you were a kid and you tried to
figure out your signature we used to
write down our signature thousands of
times pretending that's an autograph it
turns out Disneyland princesses do this
too as part of their job
according to Disneyland insiders each
character that ever works fair has to
learn how
sign their own autograph and just like
we did when we were kids they have to
practice it over and over again and how
they get it right you absolutely don't
want to write your own name on a piece
of paper from a Disney fan when they
expect to see Pocahontas I redditor who
played Mulan in Disneyland said that she
signed so many autographs it became a
habit and it actually replaced her own
signatures
she said she signs mulan's autograph
more than 1,000 times in a day and when
she got handed a paper she did it
without thinking
imagine a random woman signing Mulan on
a receipt we'd be pretty freaked out if
we saw an original Disney princess
signature outside of Disney breaking
character breaking character is a huge
topic of discussion in Disneyland know
how people always try to make the Queen
of England guards laughs some people
just want to see Disneyland princesses
break their character this just proves
the level of professionalism these
princesses have to use on the job so
even if you have some people desperately
trying to get your attention to break
your character you need to stay on your
toes that includes the times when you
get angry what a Disney Princess your
plane get angry at someone if the answer
is no you need to calm down and not
react to any situation at all it rarely
happens but have you seen the video of
Belle breaking character when she saw a
children's choir performance she got
serenaded by children from Uganda who
traveled across the world to have some
fun in Disneyland their voices made
they'll cry and although understandably
so she actually totally broke character
it's strange seeing brave Belle shed
it's here
especially since she always seems so
cheerful and happy it really shows that
Disneyland staff has to be the best
actress ever to make sure you can have
the most magical day touching stories
but not everything about working at
Disneyland is bad after all being a
Disneyland princess is a dream for many
and it definitely pays off we all know
Disney fans are some of the nicest
people ever and you get to meet them
every single day I read it her said she
played several characters at Disney and
shared a touching story about meeting a
little girl called Emily when she was
dressed as Pocahontas Emily came over to
her and gave her a card with flowers
squishing her a lovely
the next day the same woman played
Tinker Bell's friend
Silvermist guess who stopped by it was
the same little girl Emily and once
again she gave her a card with flowers
and wish Silvermist a lovely day she now
had two cards from the same girl though
wait it's not over yet a few days later
the woman played new lines and the same
little girl comes up to her and you
guessed it
she had a card with flowers before Emily
could even open her mouth the woman now
dressed as Mulan excitedly said she
knows exactly who she is she said she
heard Emily's really good at drawing
flowers because all her friends told her
unwanted attention just like in any
hospitality role sometimes being a
Disneyland princess comes with a lot of
attention from the wrong people former
Disney Princess notes that she was hit
on as Pocahontas and stated it
definitely was because of the amount of
clothing she was wearing although she
states she was never touched
inappropriately she could always see a
family with the dad or a grandpa that
would whisper things in her ear and all
this time you have to stay in character
as a Disney princess and not let
anything startle you even if it makes
you feel uncomfortable and of course a
Disney princess would never answer back
to those type of whispers unless she
remains in character and is able to come
up with something funny if there's one
thing we learned today is that all
Disneyland princesses are incredibly
brave and professional but wait we're
not even done with the secrets yet
seriously stay in character have you
ever heard a rumor that the people that
play Disney Princesses aren't exactly
nice in real life
this sometimes comes directly from the
staff cafeteria as stated by one of the
insiders it appears to be that working
at Disneyland is quite similar to
working out of any other place there's
always drama and there's always gossip
so imagine being a Disneyland princess
and taking your break after hours of
signing autographs and being on your
feet you just want some time to yourself
right you can always have some quiet
time in the break room but sometimes
even the staff expects you to always
smile and be polite but because you had
such a long day you really can't be
bothered which is why sometimes people
don't say nice things about Disney staff
the truth is we all need a break
sometimes
and that's exactly what break rooms are
for aren't they this
dori happened to another insider who
stated that she got judged when she
didn't smile or even say hello after
being exhausted from her shift it looks
like just about every workplace has
people who simply don't understand you
learn a lot about your guests remember
these are the people that come to
Disneyland's because they admire Disney
Princesses they are their role models
their inspiration and they are most
likely an important part of their
childhoods and sometimes people forget
that the princesses are just regular
people in costume so they start opening
up one of the former princesses states
that she was surprised just how much the
guests actually shared about their lives
when she was playing Rapunzel one woman
told her she lost her baby and had a
miscarriage it's not something people
would usually tell a total stranger is
it but by staying in character and
really looking and playing the part
Disney Princesses actually do bring the
magic to Disney Land and reveal that
special emotional connection the guests
had with their favorite Disney movie
it's all pretty amazing isn't it we
can't even imagine what kind of life
stories these princesses get to hear
every single day on the job so if you
ever decide to be a Disney princess be
prepared for a lot of unexpected
information you might learn about your
guests and don't forget you most likely
will have to remain in character
throughout these if this didn't convince
you to apply for that Disneyland job
wait until you hear our last untold
truth character training of course every
princess gets trained on her character
so even if someone like Rapunzel
wouldn't be your favorite you'd
absolutely have to learn everything
about her this includes watching the
movie and learning how to walk talk and
acts like Rapunzel this is usually done
during the first day of your training
each staff member gets two days of
training per character you're given so
if you're playing multiple characters it
means you might be stuck watching Disney
movies for quite a few days during your
second day in training you get to meet
and greet with guests and there might be
an additional day for accents if that's
necessary you have to maintain your
training and uphold your character
integrity at all times during meet and
greets and you even have people who are
in charge of your lines everything is
done for you even though you don't
always have someone watching to make
sure you stay in character
Disney guests will be very quick to
point out when you don't so what do you
say do you want to become a Disneyland
princess or will you just continue to
rewatch your fave movies over and over
again and that's it for our video thanks
for watching see you next time
[Music]